bring in Tim Legler covers the NBA for
the mothership not an easy segue here
legs but I do appreciate you were you in
the NBA when Mach mood was doing his
silent protest when he was actually
still Chris Jackson in Denver yeah when
he was a rookie and then I remember that
playing out I believe I still was in the
league and I think some of the context
around that was like the Gulf War and it
took on a different meaning in a context
that was Americans at war with a foreign
country and I think that's why what he
did I think you know got even more
severe backlash at that time but it's no
doubt that it definitely cost them but
when you take a stance like that that
that meaningful to you when it involves
anything to do with the country and a
national viewpoint you run the risk of
you know how are people going to
interpret this and I think that's what
this you're Colin Kaepernick situation
has been from the beginning it's
different people's interpretation of
what that means what was your reaction
to Drew Brees and then the fallout yeah
well I think as far as troubies is
concerned I think he was expressing his
own point of view but I think what we
have learned over time all of us have
artists the way that you may interpret a
particular act might not be what the
original intent was and there are times
you have to listen to the other side on
what the intent of that action is and
really take that to heart and make that
meaningful now you might still disagree
with it but when you come out and make a
public statement in any way that's a
negative reflection of it and in
basically in doing so you are saying I
really don't understand the
interpretation that you've given me on
what that means you're going to get
significant reaction and that's exactly
what happened indication drew brees do I
think he needs to be taken to the point
where you now call drew brees or racist
or things like that I think that just
takes it too far but you look at the way
he's lived his life and to what you know
all by all accounts the things he's done
in that community and just the kind of
person that he generally is regarded as
I don't know that we'd make that leap
but I do think you need to understand
there are
repercussions if you are going to voice
an opinion that differs from what the
intent of a particular action is yeah I
don't like you know we it's either black
and white from the standpoint of your
answers I either agree with you or I
don't I'm either happy for what you said
or I'm angry what you said I think drew
brees is a wonderful person
by all accounts what he's done after
Katrina the money that he donates the
importance of you know his presence in
that city I just don't agree with what
his stance on the anthem that's it if he
was on the show I'd still embrace him
for who he is and what he is but we
would disagree agree to disagree and I I
mean that's the beauty we have that
luxury here agreeing to disagree I just
don't believe that somebody is the best
person in the world or the worst person
in the world by what they say what their
opinion is you know this is a complex
issue there and it certainly is with
drew Brees I did want to talk some
basketball with you and the reason why
we were gonna have you on is we thought
this was just gonna be a normal Thursday
where we're talking about 22 teams
coming back into Orlando here I'm
confused about the format here legs why
does it have to be so complicated well I
think when you first get it and you
start to read it even for a guy like
myself and I'm waiting to see what the
format's gonna be they seem to finally
come to a consensus when you first look
at it I agree I had to read it several
times to make sure I understood what was
happening but I think it's less
complicated than maybe most people think
it is but what it comes down to is this
they made a determination to first of
all they didn't want all 30 teams down
there I think it's a great decision I
didn't want to see teams down there
playing meaningful you know five to
eight games whatever the number was
gonna be and it's shutting it down again
for several months I didn't think that
made any sense whatsoever
um I personally preferred just the 16
teams that were already in there was
enough of a gap between eight nine in my
mind that there was separation there
let's just go and get this thing started
and try to get it ended in a timely
manner what they came up with I think is
a pretty good compromise you keep more
teams interested there's six additional
teams now that have an opportunity to
close the gap on the eight seed and if
you can get it within four games
and you're in that position to be nine
you now have an opportunity to determine
your own fate and play the eight seat
and they have an advantage and that the
eight only has to beat you once you've
got to beat them twice and but at least
you can control your own destiny so I
think it keeps more teams interested
more players involved and more fans are
going to be interested at a time when we
desperately need interest in life sports
we're talking to Tim Legler ESPN NBA
analyst by the way legs played his first
NBA season 1989-90 you played in 310
career NBA games making just four starts
that right probably yeah that's that's
you know you would you get into that
mode where you're you can find a
particular role so there were times when
clearly there were times I was playing
with teams I was eating playing baby for
significant minutes or more important
minutes then the starter was and then he
would get hurt but coaches would come to
me and say listen we love what you're
bringing off the bench in your
particular role we don't want to mess
with that so they would maybe even bring
a guy that wasn't even playing in the
rotation and then make him a start I ran
into that a couple of times so it was
the only time in my life I wasn't able
to start but I was perfectly calm I
don't know if you saw CBS Sports came
out with their top 15 shooters of all
time I did did you see okay now I
thought there was a recency bias there
but I I'm okay with it like I'm not
gonna have my head explode like yeah I
did when ESPN said Michael Jordan's the
greatest college player of all time okay
now when it comes to shooting Kyle
Korver's in there Steve Kerr are in
there
this was my philosophy I just thought to
be a great shooter you have to be able
to create your shot to shoot because if
you can't get your shot off I don't care
how good a shooter you are am i
incorrect in my approach to the greatest
shooters of all time no I think that's a
component in it but I don't think you
can do just to discount the guys that
primarily were spot up 3-point shooters
because you know to do that at the level
that the guys on that list do and the
percentages they shoot how good you have
to be at that how difficult it is to get
to that level and
I think those guys have to be included
as well I mean it's for me but I think
it tell me a great shooter
I don't just necessarily think about the
guys that can go get their own offense I
think about those guys then when it
comes off their fingertip and they've
got any sort of space you've got a
really high percentage of likelihood
that that ball is gonna end up in the
bottom of the net and I have a lot of
regard for those guys I was one of those
guys so I don't think you could just
discount them I agree with you though in
terms of the list I was scratching my
head at how low they had Chris Mullin
that didn't make a lot of sense to me he
got Mullin in there at 14 I played with
that guy and going to state I know
firsthand he's certainly better than the
14th best shooter that's ever lived and
he was a guy that could get his own shot
as well by the way well who would you
put there who's your top 5 well I think
you'd go you'd probably go Steph clay
right there at the top I think Larry
Bird's got to be in the top 5 which he
was I don't remember where exactly they
had him in the list I think he was in
the top five I think that's absolutely
justified I think Kevin Durant is a guy
that you probably would have to consider
because again it's the catch and shoot
but it's also his ability to shoot those
kind of percentages from all over the
floor does ability to get to any area of
the floor with a perfect shooting stroke
I don't have a problem with including
Kevin Durant and then I would look at a
guy like Steve Nash yeah I think Steve
Nash has to be up there because you're
talking again about a guy that shoots
every year practically 50 from the field
forty to fifty from two three ninety
plus from the line and his finishing
ability like that's one thing that gets
discounted sometimes and that's why
curry for me no question number one
because in addition to his long range
stuff his ability to finish with
floaters and runners and an array of
shots with either hand that's got it
also add heavily into this and Steve
Nash was also in that category yeah I
put him in there's I think in my top
three because of what you just said I
can shoot deep I can have a mid-range
jumper I'm great from the line and I can
finish at the hoop and they're very few
guys in NBA history who can do all of
those and shoot at a high percentage I
did want to ask you about the Zion
factor with the playoffs if you had cut
and dried eight and eight if let's say
New Orleans was the eighth seed in the
West
legs would we be having 22 teams in
Orlando that's a great question ed oh
there's a lot of speculation so I'll
just give my opinion I'll say probably
not I think that plays heavily into it
and look if you're the lead you can't
blame them I mean this has been this has
been devastating financially for the
league what they've gone through so
certainly when you have a guy like that
that was that entertaining and I think
at the time this thing shut down he was
as close to must-see TV as anybody in
the league so to include him for a
minimum of eight games and potentially
more than that I think that's smart a
business decision for the league and
fortunately for them the pelicans were
within striking distance that you'd make
a really solid argument that they should
be included in this also you look at
strength of schedule the rest of the
year with Memphis and New Orleans
I think Memphis was gonna have a really
difficult time with their schedule to
hold these teams off and hold on to that
last file by the way legs once
challenged me to a three-point shooting
contest and he was gonna shoot
left-handed do you remember when you uh
absolutely offer still stands man I was
so mad at you I was like I there's no
way you're gonna beat me left-handed
from three-point range but listen I'll
tell you on my 50th birthday which was
three years ago all I wanted to do that
day I told my wife and my kids in both
of whom play we're gonna go to the local
rec center and I'm gonna make fifty
threes on my 50th birthday let's see how
long it takes me what do you think I
shot that day to make 50 what do you
think I shot over all I'm gonna say less
than 60 I was 54 56 now I get I did warm
up here's it's funny about that story I
warmed up a little bit I did it once I
actually shot better than that forgot to
record it so now here I am pretty winded
at that point and I'm saying oh my god
we got to do it again and I really
didn't think I would shoot that well so
I was pretty proud of myself Rees I will
say that they weren't NBA threes I don't
shoot that deep anymore that often but
they were to college threes but I was
still pretty proud of the accomplishment
do you think you could actually
beat me shooting left-handed nasty
laughs the like when I'm when I'm uh
just you know we're talking here just
shooting jumpers uncontested yeah pretty
good left man I got a pretty nasty well
I'll invite you to my dojo here in the
man cave
no I'll just shoot right-handed you
shoot left in get me in there get me in
there I'll beat I can't wait
Nuggets worth to the challenge Doug
Gottlieb never recovered from me
roasting him shooting threes the best
chance you would have I would say get me
somewhere like outdoors where there is
our conditions that fact they're in but
if you've got me in a climate controlled
environment and it's a problem we also
remember Greg Anthony tried to get
involved in the conversation and I
basically I said Anthony get out of here
man
you can't like I can shoot it and you
even said yeah Greg get out of here we
basically yeah
you can shoot 15-footers there Greg but
that's it these are big boy shoot
jumpers you know that's not that's not
necessarily your wheel yeah that was
great
hey legs thanks for joining us hope
you're well and we appreciate you
joining us great talking to Dan take
care that's Tim Legler